اهلا بكم من جديد عاد الى الواجهه القرار
الذي اتخذته محكمه اسبانيه بالزامي زوج
بدفعين 200 الف يورو لطليقته مقابل خمسه
وعشرين عاما من العمل المنزلي من دون اجره
وجاء في الحكم الذي استند الى قيمه الحد
الادنى للاجور طوال فتره الزواج ان الزوجه
كرست نفسها للاعمال المنزليه بشكل اساسي
ما يعني رعايه المنزل والاسره وكل ما
يتعلق بذلك كما امرت المحكمه الزوجه
السابق بان يدفع لها بدل رعايه اطفال
شهريا لابنتيهما
الزواج كان محكوما بنظام فصل البلكيه الذي
ينص على ان كل ما يكسبه كل طرف هو ملكه
وحده وترك الزوجه في هذه الحاله من دون اي
امكانيه للحصول على جزء من الاموال
المكتسبه خلال سنوات الشراكه واظهرت
الاوراق القانونيه تفصيلا ما كانت الزوجه
لتكسبه سنويا خلال الفتره الممتده بين
يونيو 1995
ديسمبر 2020 لو انها التحقت بسوق العمل
بدل البقاء في المنزل
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من
القاهره الكاتبه الصحفيه دعاء عبد السلام
ومن بيروت المحامي والناشط الحقوقيه دالا
شحاده اهلا بكما وفي البدايه لابد ان نكون
واضحا بان ما ينتج عن هذه المقابله ليس
لاي علاقه به لا اريد انا بات على الكنبه
هذه الليله
سيده دعاء هل تتفقين بانه من الواجب الدفع
للزوجه مقابل سنوات العمل في المنزل بعد
الطلاق
في الحقيقه احنا لو هنتكلم عن حقوق الزوجه
اللي بيقفلها القانون المصري انا هتكلم عن
بلدي تحديدا هو كده كده الحمد لله كافر
لها ده وبزياده انا شايفه ان بيبقى فيه
كمان تعنت اكتر في مقابل الزوج في حاله
الطلاق
بيهدر حقه في حاجات كتيره جدا من اهمها
طبعا الجانب المادي او الجانب الاقتصادي
له على اعتبار ان الست لانها ست بتعرف ان
هي تتاجر كويس جدا بقضيتها وبتعرف تستجدي
من حولها ان هي تكسب دايما اللي هي عايزاه
وتحقق التارجت اللي هي دي فانا بتكلم على
الجانب
الجانب اللي هو الست في مجتمعنا المصري
تحديدا لا هي واخده حقوقها الماديه سواء
في حاله الطلاق او حتى كمان في حاله الخرز
الزواجى ان كل واحد فينا في حاله
قصه الست المفروض بعد الطلاق هي ملهاش اي
حاجه عند زوجها او المطلق المطلقه منه لان
هو اوريدي المفروض بيبقى فيه عقد اتفاق في
عند الجواز والتزام ما بينهم هم الاثنين
في حاله ان هو حصل طلاق مؤخرها كذا فلوسها
كذا حقوقها كذا فالدنيا بتبقى بتبقى واضحه
المعالم كون ان احنا بقى
بنحاول دلوقتي
طالعه مرتبطه بقوانين واحكام المساله
علاقه انسانيه قد ينتج عنها لاطفال
الزواج وبنود واتفاقيه توقع عليها اتفقان
طرفان فلابد من الالتزام بها طيب طيب انت
اوكي الكلام
انت كده كده محمي طالما طالما انا معك انت
كده كده محمي ما تقلقش خليني اقول لحضرتك
بس جزئيه مهمه ان المفروض لما بنيجي نتجوز
المفروض الجواز اي على مقاومات معينه اهم
حاجه اللي هو بيبقى فيه نوع من انواع
الرحمه
والمحبه والاحترام مهم جدا وين حصل لا قدر
الله طلاق المفروض ان الناس
بتسوي امورها بما يرضي الله ربنا قال
تسريحه بمعروف
تسريحهم باحسان لا خلينا خلينا نتكلم بس
في جزئيه مهمه جدا ما تقاطعنيش من فضلك
اللي هي ايه الجواز في الوقت الراهن
دلوقتي ما لوش اي مقاومات ادبيه ولا دينيه
ولا اخلاقيه ولا حتى يعني نقول فيها
معايير الضمير معايير الانسانيه الفطريه
اللي ربنا خلقنا بيها دلوقتي الجواز بقى
تجاره تجاره قايمه على ان انا هدخل اعمل
بيت ومن البيت ده لان حصل ان انا كذا لازم
ابقى مكتسبه حاجات كثيره جدا حتى في حاله
الطلاق لما اجي اطلق اكون متامنه
متوازن الى حد كبير ساعود الى هذه النقطه
معك ولكن
سيده هل هل الزواج هو شركه عقود نصوص بنود
اتفاقيات ما قبل وما بعد اما انه شراكه
حقيقيه بين شخصين
الحقيقه لا فرق بين الاثنين لانه الشركه
مصطلح الشركه يعنى به شراكه بين شخصين او
اكثر وشراكه ممكن ان تكون اتفاقا شفهيا
حتى الحب هو اتفاق على الاخلاص وعلى
المعامله الحسنه لا احد يحب مجانا حتى
الام تتوقع من اطفالها ان يحسنوا اليها
بالنسبه للقرار الذي هو سبب يعني هذه هذا
النقاش القرار جدا منطقي والحقيقه ان
النفقه الزوجه غير العامله موجوده في جميع
القوانين الدينيه المتعلقه بالاحوال
الشخصيه في المحاكم الدينيه الاسلاميه
للنفقه زوجه لا تتعلق بنفقه الحضانه ثم
حتى نفق للرضاع كل هذا يترتب على الزوج
تجاه زوجته لدى الاسلام حتى لو كانت تعمل
ان تكون هذه الحقوق او هذه النفقه بئثر
يمتد ل 25 عام
يعني قانونيا
في كل الدول المسلمه تطبق الف نفقه
الزوجيه بمفعول رجعي اذا لم يتمكن الرجل
من ان يثبت بانه كان
المعلومات انا اعرف بانه الى مدى اقصر
ربما سنتين او اكثر بقليل ولكن 25 عام قد
يكون هذا حال نادره
لانه لانه في معظم النظم القضائيه يسقط
مرور الزمن في النزاعات بين الازواج لان
طبيعه هذه العلاقات هي الطبيعه تدفع نحو
تجنب النزاع وبالتالي تجنب استخدام الحقوق
القانونيه في الوقت الملازم ولذلك لا يوجد
مرور زمن على هذا النوع من الحقوق وخصوصا
الحقوق الزوجيه وانما تتوقف صحيح الحقوق
الزوجيه من نوع النفقه الزوجه وليس
الحضانه بعد انتهاء العلاقه الزوجيه وانما
تشمل كل مرحله العلاقه الزوجيه بالطالما
لم يتمكن الرجل من اثبات بانه كان يقوم
بواجبه بالانفاق على زوجه تقوم بعمل هو
عمل ما يسمى اليوم عمل غير ماجور لا يعني
عمل الزوجه داخل المنزل وهو عمل ليس سهلا
بانها يجب ان تحصل بالضروره على راتب ولكن
حين تكون الذمه الماليه منفصله وبالتالي
هي بحاجه ان تسال شيئا لنفسها في نهايه كل
هو كم واحد اصلا بعد 25 جواز بعد 25 سنه
جواز وعنده بيت واولاد ومسؤوليات هيبقى
مليونير خلينا نقول دي حاله حاله بنحاول
ان احنا نقيس بها احنا ممكن نطلع بايه لان
طبعا يعني ما فيش حد اصلا متجوز بيعرف
يعمل فلوس لان الحياه اصلا صعبه جدا
والازمات المتتاليه لاي واحد فاتح بيت
وعنده واسره واولاده وزوجه صعب ان احنا
نقول ان الحاله دي ممكن نعممها وخليني
اقول لك حاجه مهمه احنا مش منتبهين لها ان
الحاله دي اصلا ده شيء مهم للست يعني يكون
ان هي بتاجر ان هي عشره زوجها 25 سنه وان
هو بعد ما طلقه هي عايزه تاخد باثر رجعي
25 سنه يكونها ان هي وافقت من الاول انها
تبقى زوجه وامه وقاعده في البيت وان هي ما
بتعملش حاجه بعد
التعليق الاخير ربما لديالا شحاده واضح
انه كان عندك اعتراض خاصه على مساله ضد
كرامه المراه فيما يتعلق بان تحصل على
مقابل مادي مقابل الزواج
وصف المراه من مسيء وصف المراه التي تتفرغ
وتتفانى لزوجها وبيتها بانها تتاجر بهذا
التفاني لانها تطلب بدلا لنفسها عن هذا
الجهد ليس هناك بدل مادي للحب نعم ولكن
هناك بدل مادي للرعايه احتسب في هذا
القرار في المحكمه الاسبانيه بالحد الادنى
للاجور علما ان معظم المحاكم الناظره في
الاحوال الشخصيه الدينيه المسلمه
والمسيحيه وغير الدينيه دوما ما تنظر الى
نفقه الزوجه بالتناسب مع الوضع المادي
للرجل انطلاقا من كون هذه المؤسسه على
الاقل فيما بعد بدءها لنتحدث عن الاملاك
التي تسبق هذه العلاقه الزوجيه بعد هذه
الفتره ينتج عن هذه الشراكه من من مدخرات
يجب ان يتقاسمها الاثنان لانهم تقاسمان
الحياه فالقول بانها تتاجر انطلبت جزءا من
المدخرات التي حققها الرجل خلال شركته بها
وتفرغها لرعايته ولرعايه اسرتهما انها
متاجره هو اساءه للكرامه المراه اساءه
للزوج من حيث هي متفانيه في زوجها وبيتها
ونوعا ما وكان ضيفتك تقول يجب على النساء
ان يتوقفنا عن الاخلاص والتفرغ للمنزل
ويعملن فيه
توظيف موظفين وعمال باجر مضاعف عن هذا
الاجر من اجل القيام بهذه الاختلاف الدائم
اتمنى عفوا اتمنى ان نكون محايدين في
نهايه هذه الفقره من بانوراما الصحفيه
دعاء عبد السلام شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا
للمحاميه والنشاط الحقوقيه ديال شحاده كما
كان واضحا كان الحديث جدليا بشكل كبير في
الملف الاخير من
بانوراما نهايه بانوراما لهذه الليله
موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل الى اللقاء